the Senate this morning is expected to
confirm president Trump's Supreme Court
nominee Neil Gorsuch Gorsuch could be
sworn in as early as today his
confirmation vote follows a
controversial change to a long-standing
Senate rule under the so-called nuclear
option senators just need a simple
majority to confirm a Supreme Court
nominee instead of 60 votes Jan Crawford
is at the Capitol where Republicans say
Democrats force them to make the rule
change Jan good morning well good
morning or you know the only thing that
Republicans and Democrats could agree on
yesterday was that the nuclear option
will forever change the Senate I believe
our actions will haunt us poised to
change Senate rules Republicans and
Democrats offered stern warnings this
train is running over a cliff it's
taking not just the Senate with it but
the Supreme Court and we need to apply
the brakes it made no difference after
Democrats refused to end a filibuster
blocking the nomination of Neil Gorsuch
I raise a point of order the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell launched
the so-called nuclear option to change
Senate rules in some ways the horse had
already left the barn in 2013 then
Senate Majority Leader Harry Reid did
away with filibusters for lower court
nominations at the time then Minority
Leader McConnell voiced a prescient
warning say to my friends on the other
side of the aisle you'll regret this and
you may regret it a lot sooner than you
think and so on thursday in a party line
vote 52 to 48 publicans owns the rules
of the Senate to confirm justices by a
simple majority in one day the majority
has lessened the distinctions between
our chamber and our colleagues across
the Capitol senators worried the change
will create a hyper partisan environment
we're building bridges is no longer
necessary I hope I'm wrong but I think
we set in motion the eventual demise of
the Senate judge Gorsuch is replacing
the courts most conservative justice but
Justice Anthony Kennedy who is expected
to retire in the next year to is more
moderate and now confirming his
replacement will could be done even over
staunch Democratic opposition Charlie
Jan thank you so much